(crowd cheering)
- [Kelly] All right Y'all,
before we reseal the door on the
vault of "The Kelly Clarkson Show", Unseen Footage.
I have one last bit to share.
This is, What I'm Liking.
(upbeat music)
(crowd cheering)
- [Kelly] So through the hour,
You've seen great highlights
and gotten cool stories from
our band Y'all, but there's
something that happens every
day on the show that you never
get to see. After I say, "have
a great day, and if it's not,
change it". The band plays
out with the credits.
For You at home, the music
gently fades, here on the stage
it ain't so gentle. It goes
on, and sometimes on and on and
on and on.
(upbeat music)
(music continues)
- [Kelly] Thank You guys,
Y'all have a great night.
I'm going home.
(crowd cheering)
- [Kelly] Oh My God.
- [Kelly] Just thrusting.
I'm just, You don't know what
You're doing until they play
it back. I haven't, I haven't
seen it until just now.
(crowd laughing)
- [Kelly] And it's a lot of
thrusting. For the life of me,
I can't figure out why I'm
single. Wow! I'm a lot of person.
It's awesome. Okay, So at this
point in the show we usually
give our guests a thousand
dollars courtesy of our season
long partner, Pilot Pin. Makers
of G-2, the go-to pin of the
Kelly Clarkson show, but today
we are donating that money to
an organization, not just
close to Jason's heart but all
of ours. Jason's daughter
Kennedy was diagnosed with Cancer
as a teenager. After a very
difficult battle, she's Cancer
free.
(crowd cheering)
- [Kelly] And now, She's
dedicated to helping other kids
facing that challenging
journey by working with the
Rally Foundation for
Childhood Cancer Research.
So, thanks to Pilot Pin the
Rally Foundation is getting a
cheque for a $1,000.
(crowd cheering)
- [Kelly] And that's not
all. I'm being told that our
director, Joe Terry is going
to add an additional $5,000
as well. So, the Rally Foundation
is getting $6,000 for the
important work that they do.
And actually that's not all.
I'm gonna throw 5,000 in as
well. So, They're gonna have a
little thousand to it, all right?
(crowd cheering)
- [Kelly] Thank You to all our
guests, the Backstreet Boys,
new kids on the block. Salt and pepper.
(continuous cheering)
- [Kelly] And Rogue, Michael
Bubble, Randy Jackson,
Den Reynolds, Shekila Neo, Avril lavigne.
And especially every single
member of my band, Y'all.
Jason, Jessie, Jackal, Kyle
and Lester. Y'all are the best.
They are so talented. Have
a great day Y'all and if
it's not, well, try and change it. Bam.
(upbeat music)